Speaker 1: All right. It's been a while. But let's
talk a little bit about Carrie Lake, who is moving
on to her next. Likely grift running for Senate
in Arizona. It seems maybe she's getting ready
to give up on taking that governorship back
that was stolen from her, which of course,
wasn't stolen. She simply lost to Katie Hobbs,
the rightful winner. And the now governor of
the state of Arizona, Carrie Lake, is starting
to tease that she may indeed run for Senate.
We are going to look at a video from Charlie
Kirk's program. You might notice Charlie Kirk
now adopting a totally new look, getting himself
some big glasses and wearing a shirt and tie and I
guess maybe needing to be taken more seriously
or something along those lines. He interviews
Carrie Lake and Carrie Lake says, you know, I
it is something I am looking at very strongly.
And we already have polling data of what this
will look like. Let's take a look at this clip.
Speaker 2: Some people are clamoring
for you to run for the U.S. Senate.
Speaker 1: Very few people, I can tell you that.
Speaker 2: I had a lot of people reach
out this weekend over it. Yeah, we.
Speaker 1: Got people there contacting.
That's exactly what people do. They go, hey, you
know what? I want Carrie Lake to run. I'm going to
call Charlie Kirk to tell him about it.
Speaker 2: I ego running cinema might
run. Therefore there's a very clear lane
for a three way race. Is this something
you're interested in? Something you're
entertaining? What are your thoughts?
Speaker 3: Yes, I am entertaining it.
I mean, my number one priority is our
court case, and I have full confidence.
Speaker 1: She has to say that because
you have to keep that grift going until you've
completely dried it, until it has completely
dried up. But also, she's entertaining a
different way to help Arizonans, which is
to run for senator, I guess, a court case.
Speaker 3: And I have hope that we'll get a
judge to do the right thing. But I'm also looking
at what happens if we don't get a decent ruling
in that. Right. And they want me to go away. They
want our movement to go away. I represent we the
people. And if they want us gone so badly
that they're willing to steal an election.
Speaker 1: That which didn't happen.
Speaker 3: I'm not going to let them have that. I
won't go away. And I've seen some internal polling
that shows I am the only Republican who can beat
these other two. I find both of them incredibly
dangerous to the people of Arizona. They are
I find them. You know. PIERSON Cinema's voting
record being 83% or rather 93% of the time voting
for Joe Biden's agenda. I find Ruben Gallego being
a self-admitted socialist, really frightening for
Arizona. And if I'm the only Republican who
can beat them, I would be willing to jump in.
Speaker 1: There's always this martyred martyrdom
language. Did you hear what the energy says? If
I'm the only Republican who can beat them? Right.
This is despite her best interests. If she just
finds herself in the position of being the only
person that could actually come in and save the
state of Arizona, she's willing to do it. She's
not didn't want to do it. She's in excited about
doing it. She's willing to do it rather than the
more interesting and exciting things I guess,
that she could be doing. Now. We do have some
early polling in that hypothetical matchup. We
talked about this in late December. Poll finds
cinema gets only 13% support in a three way race
with a gay ego and lake. And roughly the way that
it looks right now and we have a longer clip just
talking about this polling it's basically a tie
between Gallego and Lake with or without Kyrsten
Sinema. So it was something like 48 to 47, I
think it was when you don't include Kirsten Cinema
in Lake versus Gallego, excuse me.
And if you do include Kyrsten Sinema,
it's something like 4041. And so what was
interesting about that is Kari Lake and Gallego
roughly receiving 5050 support from Kirsten
Cinema voters. I'm going to take a sip of water.
Thank you. I don't want one of those Fox News
moments, so I will carry Lake ultimately run.
I don't know if it'll get her attention, if
it'll get her back to Mar a Lago or whatever
the case may be. But Kerry Lake going to
do whatever it is that is best for her